And I'm going to be discussing, so sorovatamig, as you know, is not yet approved, but I'm going
to be presenting the first in human data. And my apology, one of my slides got flipped. Yeah.
So sorovatamig is a CD19 Bispecific. And as we know, the currently approved bispecifics
are mostly CD20. And there's a huge unmet need for other targets for bispecifics,
not only in lymphoma, but also in ALL, where we currently have blenatumab, which, as you know,
is like a continuous infusion. So sorovatamig is a CD19 bispecific. It's designed in such a way
that the CD19 binding site has high affinity to the B cells, but the CD3 binding site has a lower
affinity. Theoretically, you know, that the purpose was to reduce the CRS incidence.
So this is, this was a basket trial, included a lot of types of lymphomas. We're going to be
focusing on the follicular lymphoma and diffuse large B cell lymphoma today. The way that it's
administered, it's intravenous. During cycle one, there's a step-up dosing. It went through many
iterations. This is the double step-up dosing. But right now, there's also, we're also developing a
three-step-up dosing approach to, again, mitigate some of the toxicities. After the ramp-up for
cycle one, patients get it every two weeks.
And for those who achieve a CR after cycle six, and they, they, they have at least two imaging
showing CR, they could go to once a monthly treatment for a total of up to two years. So
this is also a time-limited therapy. And so this is the diffuse large B cell lymphoma cohort. And
again, you know, these are just the inclusion and the, you know, the key eligibility criteria.
There's MRD built into the study as well. Patients, you know,
who are enrolled were, had at least two prior lines of therapy. So this is the diffuse large
B cell lymphoma cohort. And you could look at the demographics. This is a very high risk
group of patients. The study was really very inclusive. So it enrolled patients who had
prior exposure to CAR-T cell therapy, CD2 at 20 bispecifics, bulky disease, double-hit lymphoma,
refractory disease. And you could see here that there were some patients who were CD20 negative,
and these patients, you know, may not respond to the currently approved
CD20 bispecifics, for example. The lines of therapy with the median was three, but you could
see here, some patients had up to 13 lines of therapy. The, if you look at the prior treatments,
again, almost half of the, half of these patients had failed prior CAR-T cell therapy. Two patients
had an allo. There were 15% of patients had prior bispecifics, CD20 bispecific. So this is the
efficacy in the diffuse large B cell lymphoma cohort. And again, this is the efficacy in the
diffuse large B cell lymphoma cohort. And, you know, these are the different dose levels. And
you could clearly see there is, you know, higher responses with higher dose levels. The final
dose level that we're going to go for, for the phase two trial is the 25 milligrams. So far,
the overall response is 77% with a CR rate of 54%. Again, this is a single agent. There is also MRD
built in. The patients who do achieve a CR, you could clearly see that those
responses can be durable. And obviously we need longer follow-up to, to clarify that.
In terms of MRD, so of the 25, of the 29 patients who had CR, the majority of them were MRD negative,
so 90%. And you could clearly see from the, the swimmer's plot here that patients achieve MRD
negativity on average, you know, close to two months or so. So again, if it works, it works
quickly and these responses can be durable. This is just one example for a patient. And again,
you know, we all see these patients in clinic who have failed CAR-T cell therapy or failed
a CD20 by specific. And unfortunately, you know, these patients had typically have low responses.
This is a patient who had third line epitomab and you could clearly see that, you know,
they had an excellent response here. It's not just this patient. We all have like a lot of
other patients on the study as well. Toxicity wise. So the CRS and the diffuse large B cell lymphoma cohort was
seen evenly during the step-up dosing. However, so the total CRS was, was seen in half of, half of
the patients. The vast majority of these were grade one, 42%, with 6% having grade two. So
those typically, you know, happen within 24 hours, sometimes 48 hours. It typically lasts for about a
day. The vast majority of patients, it subsides spontaneously. The use of tusolucumab here on the
study was, was 29%.
And 3% received steroids. In terms of ICANNs, so ICANNs was, the overall was 27%. There were some patients, a few
patients who had a grade three ICANNs, 8%, but the rest were mostly grade one and two. And again,
the ICANNs here with these bispecifics, it's typically something that happens the next day
or the day after. A lot of those included confusion, aphasia, disorientation, and it
typically lasts about a day. We usually start those patients on steroid, and it usually resolves
on its own. And again, this is still a moving target because the, the, the ramp-up dosing has
been, is still, you know, modified, and we're now going to with, with a three-step-up dosing
approach. In terms of the follicular lymphoma cohort, now the, we had 61 patients here,
and you could see the, you know, the, the demographics here. So 36% of patients had POT24,
these are high-risk patients. 11% had failed prior CAR-T, 8% had failed prior Bispecific.
The efficacy is very, very, very promising in follicular lymphoma. So the, at the 15 milligram
dose and at the 7.2 milligram dose, you could see here very high response rates, 96% with a CR rate
of 92% overall. And if you look here, so the, the, these, this is the MRD,
so of the patients who have MRD-evaluable data, the MRD, by the way, was done with a clarity assay.
So 95% of patients who are MRD-eligible and they were in CR had detectable MRD. So again,
very promising. And as you, as you can see, you know, from the swimmer's spot,
these MRD negativity, they, they, they happen really early on. So the dose that's currently
moving forward in the phase two trial is the 7.2 milligrams for the follicular lymphoma. In terms
of the MRD-evaluable data, the MRD-evaluable data, the MRD, by the way, was done with a clarity assay.
In terms of adverse events, so obviously you have, you know, a lot of these by adverse events that
you could see with, with bispecifics, including some cytopenias, sometimes infections. But the
CRS rates were, you know, for follicular lymphoma, overall was half of the patients, but these were
mostly grade one, so mostly fevers. And again, typically happen within a day or two. The ICANS
in the follicular lymphoma cohort was, was low compared to the diffuse large vessel lymphoma
cohort at, at 5%. And again, you know, mostly there's just two patients, one had grade one,
another had grade two. And as I mentioned, these are typically reversible within, within a day.
Next step, so it's being looked at now in, in, in a lot of, you know, other trials ongoing. So the
Soundtrack F1 is, is looking at, at this sorovatamib with rituximab in previously untreated
follicular lymphoma in a phase three trial with a comparator arm.
Chemoimmunotherapy. Soundtrack P is, is a phase two registrational looking at follicular lymphoma
and diffuse large B cell lymphoma cohorts currently enrolling. And Soundtrack E is looking at other
histologies, including CLL, mantle cell, and large cell lymphoma cohorts. There's also, I didn't show
it here, there's also an ALL study going on in patients with relapsed ALL. Thank you for your
attention.